in Poway California this individual was
with a a our yard type assault weapon
and opened fire on the people inside the
the synagogue during the shooting four
individuals were wounded and transported
to Palomar hospital sadly one of the
individuals succumb to their wounds the
other three are in stable condition at
Palomar as the suspect was fleeing the
temple an off-duty Border Patrol agent
opened fire on the suspect but
apparently did not hit him but struck
the cars at the part of the area the
people at Palomar one is a female
juvenile in stable condition and two
adult males are in stable condition
sadly an older female died from and
succumbed to her wounds she obtained in
the shooting the suspect was shortly
taken into custody and I'll turn it over
to chief big news light from San Diego
Police Department to give you the
details of that arrest chief good
afternoon
as this incident was unfolding a San
Diego police officer k-9 officer was in
route to the scene he was monitoring
both the Sanna Police Department
dispatch and the sheriff's dispatch
heard the call and started making his
way towards this call as he was in route
he also overheard a CHP scanner of a
suspect who it's called in to CHP to
report that he was just involved in this
shooting and his location which was
Rancho Bernardo in the interstate 15 as
our officer was actually in the freeway
he clearly saw the suspect his vehicle
suspect pulled over jumped out of his
car with his hands up and was
immediately taken into custody by the
Sandy Police Department as the officer
was placing this 19 year-old male into
custody he clearly saw a rifle sitting
on the front passenger seat of the
suspect vehicle on the suspect as I said
was taken into custody without any
further incident
this investigation will be led by the
Sante County Sheriff's Department but
it'll be a joint investigation with a
San Diego Police Department and the
federal investigation with us this
afternoon is acting Special Agent in
Charge
Omer mais el Homer thank you
first and foremost we'd like to offer
our deepest condolences to the victims
of this tragedy tragedy as soon as we
were made aware of the incident the FBI
deployed resources immediately to the
scene we've deployed all relevant assets
to assist with this investigation we're
working closely with our local state and
the United States Attorney's Office on
the investigation the San Diego County
Sheriff's Department provides law
enforcement services to the city of
Poway we're joined here this afternoon
and like say a few words by the mayor
Poway Steve Fossen
I want you to know this is not Poway the
Poway I know comes together as we did
just a few weeks ago at an interfaith
event we always walk with our arms
around each other and we will walk
through this tragedy with our arms
around each other we have deep
appreciation for those who showed
courage at the Habad deep appreciation
for the law-enforcement agencies that
responded so quickly we will get through
this our thoughts and prayers will be
with the families and those who are
investigating how 'we will stay strong
and we will always be a community that
cares for one another the
anti-defamation league and our trauma
intervention teams have set up a Family
Assistance Center at Poway High School
to be available to anybody that wants
their services so I would commend people
in the community to come together and
maybe meet at Poway to talk about the
grief that we're all suffering right now
we will be back in an about two hours
with more details as the investigation
unfolds I'll take a few questions if you
have any right now
we don't we're not going to release that
right now he's it's in the process of
being interviewed by homicide
investigators from the Sheriff's
Department and the FBI will have those
details later but we have copies of his
social media posts and his open letter
and we'll be reviewing those to
determine legit as' legitimacy of it and
and exactly how it plays into the
investigation I don't have the exact
number of shell shots that were being
fired the crime scene is being done as
we speak I'm sorry
I do not know we have an address for him
here in San in San Diego he's in the
city of San Diego yes he's an adult male
from the city of San Diego I'm sorry
yeah we have there are a lot of people
still at the synagogue we need to be
interviewed by homicide investigators I
heard this close to a hundred people
waiting to be interviewed I couldn't
give you the exact number I know there's
about a hundred people to be interviewed
right now I couldn't tell you sorry not
that I know I I don't I don't know all
the details on the victims we're not
going to discuss that right now while
the investigation is ongoing
my understanding he was inside the
synagogue when the shooting broke out I
don't know those details will be back in
about two hours hopefully with some more
details for you thank you very much
again I'm Sheriff Bill Gore but I'm here
to provide update on the the tragic
shooting at the Habad a mosque this
afternoon the suspect has been widely
reported identified the suspect as John
Ernest date of birth six 899 age 19 is a
San Diego resident as best we can tell
had had no prior arrest records in San
Diego we're currently preparing search
warrants which the timely process for
the residents Ernst residents for his
vehicle and for the mosque in PAL waive
pardon me for the synagogue in Poway
we're collecting digital evidence and
we're aware of his manifesto which we're
in the process of reviewing to determine
its validity and authenticity as you
know one person tragically died in the
shooting today and update on the the
other victims ones currently gone into
surgery the adult male one adult male is
in stable condition at the hospital and
the juvenile has been in stable
condition is Beach he's been transported
to radies Children's Hospital we're
currently working with the Escondido
Police Department and the FBI the
terminal earns possible involvement in
the arson at the mosque and Escondido
about a month ago and the additional the
San Diego Sheriff's Department and the
San Diego police firing to conduct
conducting additional patrols at house
of worship throughout San Diego County
as I stated before the anti-defamation
league is offering crisis trauma
counseling at Poway high school and
there's also a county crisis line is
available to anybody that needs their
services that's eight eight eight seven
two four seven two four zero that's 24
hours a day seven days a week we urge
everyone to stay vigilant and report any
unusual circumstances to 911 they will
be promptly investigated and responded
to we're lucky in San Diego County to
have the kind of cooperation we do just
a few of the agencies have been working
on this case so far the with the
Sheriff's Department of San Diego Police
Department San Diego Fire San Diego FBI
California Highway Patrol Escondido
Police Department ATF California Office
of Emergency Services and the u.s.
Border Patrol also with me today giving
Mayor Steve Austin Poway and the acting
special agent charge of the FBI lovely
Susanna Turner and behind me congressman
Scott Peters we'd be happy to answer any
questions you have at this time his name
is
John Ernest date of birth six 899 he's
19 years old and as far as we can tell
us had no prior contact with law
enforcement we're looking at the
possible
what type of that well some of the
digital evidence that we're reviewing
right now I can't go any more detail on
that as far as I can tell right now it's
a it's a assault type rifle a RIE ar-15
typewriter I don't have specifics well
it's clearly it's being investigated as
a homicide but we're also looking at the
hate crime possible violation as well as
federal civil rights violations I'm not
going to go into that now he'll be he's
been thoroughly interviewed by homicide
detectives and FBI agents I'm sorry
[Music]
we don't right now have any connection
between mr. earnest and a white
supremacist groups we have no record of
police contact prior today
prior to I'm not aware of I need to know
her we're also hearing that he attempted
to livestream
I can't confirm that right now
to this point no explosives been found
at the synagogue yes
as far as I know yes that's correct no
there was not
know the status of the witnesses they're
still let the my understand is there at
the the rabbis house behind the
synagogue waiting to be contacted by FBI
agents and deputy sheriff's
I would refer that to the the the
synagogue I don't know what their their
media plans will be as far as we will
have extra patrols in the area as will
San Diego Police Department around most
of our house of worship in in San Diego
County hopefully nobody will try to
copycat this this tragic event here that
took place in Poway today yeah if my
understanding is the rabbi was one of
the individuals that was injured in the
shooting well as I stated before there
was a border patrol officer off duty at
the at the synagogue and as the parents
was leaving the facility he obtained a
weapon and engaged in gunfire and shot
at earnest I did not hit him but there
was a appears that he did make did put
some bullet holes in the car that Ernst
was driving
as a security guard I believe what can
you tell us about the victim how many
shots
I don't have those details we're not
sure a lot of this will be developed
during the investigation there's
indications that its gun might have
malfunctioned
after firing numerous rounds well I
think we've seen these tragic events all
over the United States and all I can
tell the people out there that see this
on their TV is that your law enforcement
agencies federal state and local in San
Diego County are vigilant and we will
provide the type of security hopefully
that will prevent this from happening in
the future but sadly we're seeing this
happen all too often around our country
and it's tragic especially when it
happens here in our own backyard okay if
you have any other updates through the
sheriff and through a media release of
anything else breaks thank you